alors commencé avec notre info people du
jour s'agit bien sûr du décès de luke
perry l'interprète de dylan mckay dans
la série beverly hills franchement
toutes les meufs était un mode amoureuse
oui estiment céder le bon bien sûr bien
sûr je l'aimé bien plus sa voiture c'est
ça et écart où il ya treize premières
amours
regardez c'est vrai qu'il avait
cinquante deux ans il a été victime d'un
avc
le 27 février dernier
[Musique]
si vous étiez ado dans les années 90 ces
quelques notes de génériques ne peuvent
définitivement pas vous laisser
indifférent
si bien entendu le générique de la série
culte beverly hills qui a bercé toute
une génération d'adolescents qui suivait
chaque jour les aventures de dylan
brenda brandon kelly et donna mais alors
que la série devait connaître une
nouvelle version exceptionnelle de six
épisodes prochainement c'est une triste
nouvelle qu'on a pris hier les fans de
la série en effet l'acteur luke perry
qui incarnait le rôle de dylan est
décédé hier à l'âge de 52 ans luke perry
alias dylan dans la série beverly hills
est décédé des suites d'un avc il avait
seulement 52 ans dylan mckay le beau
gosse le bad boy du lycée dans les 20
litres
la star qui tenait également depuis
quelques années l'un des rôles titres de
la série bordel a été hospitalisé fin
février suite à un avc
la popularité de cette série et du
personnage incarné par l'ue perry était
telle que dans les années 90 en france
de nombreux enfants ont été baptisés
dylan en 1996 se sont même près de 7000
enfants qui porteront ce prénom non loin
derrière le prénom thomas
je connais voyage plein de copains qui
s'appelle dylan boutboul
non mais c'est vrai vous voulez tout ça
est le nombre de lots non le nom après
quoi c'est pas du tout aimé way et c'est
vrai que l'iccat risque lui ouais les
mecs se faisait la même cicatrices que
lui sur le sourcil toute la génération
des 18 20 travel à 104 et sur neige à 4
et sur les chaussées susurrait c'est sûr
que ça représente quelque chose pour toi
ma ba oui bah oui j'étais bâches et je
suis arrivé j'étais en plein dedans quoi
on regarde et je crois que c'est tous
les dimanches il me semble et ce à la
demande déprimée avec ma mère on
regardait tout le temps il y avait mon
frère et wim la veille avait steve aussi
je rappelle de me rappelle l'hostis
voileux leblond la l'insupportable
il est tout à fait je me qui fait parce
qu'ils voient y'avait brenda brenda
walsh avait appelé de david silver moi
je le kiffe et des russes c'est pas du
tout là derrière ils ont dit que le père
y compris qu'une photo le quart david
silver vous rappeler ou pas oui c'était
mon préféré il avait joué par brian
austin green et il ya eu plein de crédit
aussi parce qu'il y avait qualité lors
oui c'est pour ça que votre maman vous
appliquer ou non ma di santa barbara
d'accord d'accord que d'autres délires
ouais non c'est un délire voilà donc
c'est vrai que luke perry tout on a
parlé hier ici juste à mohon pour les
femmes de l'udc perd et on le verra
bientôt dans le nouveau film de quentin
tarantino exact de dicaprio et il était
aussi il était aussi à la tête de
riverdale c'est vrai donc voilà il
travaille à los angeles au moment de son
avc sur le tournage de cette série qui
est un véritable carton